[Music]  so guess what  on Sundays Keeping Up with the  Kardashians  Kim Kardashian revealed some pretty big  news to her family what happens every  time I say guess what we're having a  baby a girl Chloe clearly thrilled to  see Kim welcome her third child via a  surrogate as for momma Kris her reaction  was a bit emotional Kim and Kanye's baby  girl on the way will be the seventh  grandchild in the family while sisters  Chloe and Kylie have yet to confirm  their pregnancies Kim opened up to et  last month about preparing for baby  number three knowing that I was able to  carry my first two babies and not you  know my baby now that is hard for me so  it's definitely a harder experience than  I anticipated just in the control area I  think when you are pregnant by the time  you have the baby you're so prepared and  so ready and now I'm just like oh my god  I'm gonna freak out because I'm not  ready and I'm not prepared but it'll  just all come into place  [Music]